If you're ready, let's go through the code to reshape our
data frame into a new one. First, let's install and load the
R reshape two package. Now, let's create a variable for a
new data frame that will be in wide format. I'll use the
same variable name for the data frame and just add wide
to the end. Now, we're going to make use of the dcast
function, which comes with the R shape two package. The letter d
is used since we want the result to be a data frame.
If we wanted an array or a matrix we could use a
cast. We specify the data set we are going to change and then
we put in a formula. So, here's the data frame I want to
modify and then this is where I'll enter my formula. Now, the first
part of the formula, or the part to the left of the Tilly
sign, will list the variables I want to keep with an addition side in
between them. Here I just want to keep h. On the right side
of the tilda, we use the gender variable since we want male and
female users to have their own columns for median friend count
in the data frame. And finally, we set value dot var equal
to median friend count because value dot var holds the key measurements
or their values in our new data frame. And it looks like
that I forgot quotes around this variable. So let me add
that. Now, we should get a new data frame. And let's look
at some of these data frames, so that way, we can make
sure we understand this dcast function. Here are some of the rows
printed out and notice I have my age column, my female median friend count and
my male median friend count. See if you can recreate these steps on your own and
try playing around with the D cast and
Nill functions, and the reshape to package. The
Nill function will allow you to convert the
Y data back to the original long format